esta es la entrada a algunas viviendas
estatales en el distrito de haidian en
el noroeste de china y fue acordonada
después de que un residente salió
positivo de kobe 19 de hecho toda el
área de 230 mil metros cuadrados se
encuentra bajo cuarentena y sus
habitantes tienen prohibido salir
además estrictos protocolos de limpieza
y desinfección han sido implementados y
la gente viviendo en esta área tendrá
que hacer cinco pruebas en el primer día
y cuarto día séptimo día además en el
día 14 y 21 de la 40
en nanjing la capital de la provincia de
jiangxi en el este de china los casos
también están incrementando la ciudad
empezó su cuarta ronda de pruebas de
diagnóstico viral ya sea en patios de
recreo en gimnasios o en pistas de
atletismo finalmente llegamos a wuhan en
china central la ciudad en donde el
coronavirus apareció por primera vez hoy
un puñado de contagios comunitarios se
reportaron entre trabajadores migrantes
y los oficiales en diferentes partes del
país no se arriesgan
restringió los viajes al extranjero de
sus ciudadanos como medida para frenar
el repunte de contagios el último brote
conectado con la variante delta llega
después de que china celebraba llevar el
número de contagios domésticos a casi
cero permitiendo una reactivación
económica